parliament's probe into the surveillance
program of America's national security
agency has finally wound up with a
series of recommendations designed to
protect the digital privacy of Europe
citizens the inquiry began after
whistleblower Edward Snowden's
revelations of the NSA's activities the
civil liberties committee called for
suspension of an eu-us agreement on
customer data storage withholding
consent on a big trade agreement unless
fundamental rights are respected and
giving international protection to
whistleblowers what we have ended up
with is a condemnation of systematic
blanket collection of personal data
where it is not specifically abused for
security purposes amid public anger at
austerity measures imposed by Brussels
the European Central Bank has been
explaining its position and outlining
its vision of the future to M eps the
ECB joins the International Monetary
Fund and the European Commission in
forming the troika the body pursuing
austerity in four countries that have
needed bailouts we are very aware of Z
of the social hardship in the program
countries many citizens have suffered
but we should not jump to the wrong
conclusions and blame as a fire brigade
for the fire damage m eps are carrying
out an inquiry into the troika and are
anxious to know what comes next they are
patient what is knock for chemo delta
troika aft important desk image of
traits routine see assyria far honk
before to answer new community law
making its successor legally watertight
so maybe peace however want it and the
austerity measures that have caused so
much hardship one down key for
absolutely no fair I'm plan de
recuperacion social Ellen blah
money laundering is becoming a growing
scourge that can't be dealt with on a
national level according to mep s
through the banking system through
online gambling and gambling syndicates
and through human trafficking among many
criminal activities mep s have approved
a whole raft of measures to tighten
expand and enhance existing anti-money
laundering measures we need to protect
herself and sometimes I think we have
bit we have been slow and we have been a
bit naive we have tracked prompt